ready DJ can you give me a thumbs up
okay great good evening everyone
welcome to state of the city
2025 it is my last one and I cannot
believe
it so I'm so excited to be with you
tonight to share highlights of the last
year some Reflections and a look ahead
but first things first happy Black
History Month
[Music]
[Applause]
here in the our little city there is a
lot going on Lancaster history is
elevating uh the contributions of Lydia
Hamilton Smith and her role in the
anti-slavery movement right at the
corner of uh Vine and South Queen Street
I'm also really thrilled that Chestnut
housing has named their latest project
Dina's Hill Apartments honoring The Life
and Legacy of Dina McIntyre you can clap
Dina was a formerly enslaved woman who
who became who won her freedom and uh
went on to become a property owner of
several Parcels in the Strawberry Hill
Neighborhood and soon beyond the lookout
for the witness Stones a collaboration
of the African-American Historical
Society of south central Pennsylvania
historic Rock Ford and the school
district of
Lancaster uh so black history is all
around us friends so uh just uh take
some time get to know about our history
as a city I know this is something that
when I moved here in I don't know what
year was that 07 it was hard to find um
this history and now it is um becoming
more and more uh available to the
general public and also is going to
become more and more available to the
folks that are visiting our community
from around the
globe so I'd like to recognize a few
people that are here tonight tonight so
first um I'm going to give a shout out
to representative uh Nikki Rivera and
her colleague izy Smith wayal um today
was the passage of this of was the
introduction not the passage the
introduction of the state budget so they
had a full day um but Nikki sent me a
text wishing me well and um I know that
U we are excited um for that state
budget always to get ped on time uh so
we appreciate that today was the the
first step I'd also like to recognize
and this can we put the lights up a
little bit I'd also like to recognize
commissioner Yoder Alice Yoder who's in
the house thank you for being here
tonight and we have members of Lancaster
City Council and we have uh our
Treasurer I think I saw and controller
could you all stand all the elected
officials just stand up
all right ah and we have we have an mdj
in the house thank you for being here
okay
awesome thank you
all you know it's easy sometimes it's
easy to to stand up here um and take
credit for all the work but this is a
job that is um that I get to do because
there are 600 people behind me and so if
you are one of those 600 people that
were for the city of Lancaster will you
please stand
up really
awesome so and last but not least I get
to rep um recognize my mom who's here
thank you
Bonnie today I don't I don't need to
tell my mom this but today is would have
been my parents 55th wedding anniversary
so my dad's not with us anymore but um
Love Never Dies Mom love
you and I have my sister who's in the
house thank you Renee I have my in-laws
John and Judy reck Nagel thank you for
being here and Margie my mom's friend
who thank you for bringing being the
driver tonight appreciate
that and um I'll have more to say about
my dear sweet husband later
okay he's also in the house I'm glad
that business trip got
cancelled all right let's begin with a
quick look back to my first year in
office here I am on day one brimming
with excitement and that first day on
the job feeling that all things are
possible my brother-in-law quipped that
I was sworn in so that I could get sworn
at and 14 days later boy did I get sworn
at a lot of parking tickets were issued
because folks didn't move their cars for
street sweeping because it had snowed
fast forward today to today and we are
street cleaning which could be street
sweeping or plowing and that my friends
was the day I got even clearer that we
needed to do a better job communicating
with our residents and it is an
NeverEnding
task a few months later following a
contentious city council meeting I got a
call very early in the morning that a
fire had been set at City Hall following
an investigation we learned that the
perpetrator paid $40 to a guy from York
to do this in retaliation for actions
that my admin Administration took to
address neglectful housing
conditions we learned a lot from that
experience but our commitment to
ensuring safe housing has remained
steadfast last year our inspectors
completed 5,000 inspections we've made
changes to our ordinances that have
increased our efficiencies as a team and
we are doing more with fewer
staff we created the first Department of
neighborhood engagement and as a
community reimagined how we collaborate
with our neighbors making sure that new
voices were at the table no matter what
neighborhood you live in or what
language you
speak
yeah our work building engagement has
been nationally recognized in February
that's this month already a new case
study by the local policy lab which is a
national nonprofit profet that works to
support Civic engagement will be
released highlighting our efforts and
another round of love your block grants
is coming on Valentine's
Day I also um just want to give a shout
out to um part of our Civic engagement
includes the neighborhood leaders
Academy and that's been a partnership
with the uh JP mccy high school so we've
got a whole bunch yeah we can give a
shout out for JP
um has been engaged ing a a lot of
students and the most recent class uh
we're working with wow they have big
ideas about how to effectuate change in
our city in the ways that they see needs
as young people and I also want to give
a shout out to church World Service
who's going through some really hard
times right now but they have also had a
neighborhood leaders Academy for newly
arriving refugees to help people Orient
to our form of government how to
interact with our police how to um use
911 how to to uh identify when they need
to call our housing inspector that
program was also really critical as part
of our Civic engagement efforts and if
you haven't been paying much attention
to what's happening with CWS I encourage
you to follow along and engage as you
can okay a few weeks after the
firebombing there was a teasing incident
in June of 2018 which put Lancaster City
in the news globally I mean I was
hearing from from hundreds of people
phone calls and emails demanding change
from as far away as Germany and Brazil
to right here in our little city this
led to a lot of learning for me about
our use of force policy which ultimately
was Rewritten to reflect current best
practices and I thought nothing nothing
could beat
2018 and the challenges that came our
way and I was really happy to have that
year in between for of a reset but I was
so wrong do you all remember
this then George Floyd was murdered
protests erupted around the world and
our commitment to racial Equity was
renewed a commitment that remains
through our intentional Investments
policies and
procedures coming out of covid we were
awarded $ 39.5 million in American
Rescue plan act funds which allowed us
to make historic Investments in housing
and homelessness Services Community
benefit organizations and it helps
supplement our budget keeping our staff
employed and our property taxes flat
These funds were a game
Cher and if you just like the best part
of my job is going to hang out with
those little people that are on the
right um those are kiddos from Univision
and they're just
exceptional so turning now to Public
Safety this is the largest investment
that taxpayer make taxpayers make every
year um in our police and fire bureaus
and I am so proud of our police Bureau
and the work that they are doing
together we have been through a lot
during my time as mayor the leadership
of Chief Richard Mendes and his Command
Staff has been instrumental in leading
change growing up on South Queen Street
I'm not sure that he thought that he
would be the first Hispanic police chief
in the city's history but then life
leads you places that you don't
predict calls to the police Bureau have
gone down over time and they have stayed
down reflecting the impact of our
proactive efforts cumulatively as a city
following a comprehensive Staffing Study
last year we are now able to reduce our
Target number of total officers to
128 down from
145 over the past few years we've
overhauled our recruitment efforts and
have brought on new officers and we need
more our applications for new officers
and Cadets just opened on February the
1st so help us spread the word and
Sergeant McGregor's in the back if you
want to go say
hi our detective division exceeds the
national averages averages and bringing
cases to closure meaning that they solve
crimes and bring Justice to
victims we've also added a new police
social worker to the team Kelly who's
pictured here on the right Grace and
Kelly have left LED with compassion and
tenacity because navigating the social
systems and networks um that are
available for support is hard especially
for our most vulnerable and they have
helped our most vulnerable get accesses
access to the services that they need
I'm particularly reminded of a story
that I heard about their work getting an
elderly gentleman off the street and
into a nursing home and it had been the
first time he had been in a bed in
months
and stay tuned the bureau is on the cusp
of becoming an accredited police Agency
for the first time ever and it has been
a process so this is just one more
example of the ways in which our police
Bureau is continuing to
lead now turning to the fire Bureau wow
when I came on board in 2018 there
hadn't been promotional testing in a
while and since then we have built a
leadership team now that is led by Todd
Hutchinson and this team will let me
tell you we have four members that are
credentialed as Chief officers there are
only 54 in the whole state we have five
credentialed uh I'm sorry yes five
credentialed fire officers and there are
only 40 fos in the whole state and we
have one credentialed as a fire marshal
there's only six in the whole state this
is impressive and speaks to the
commitment to training and Excellence
that our fire Bureau has taken on uh and
I really appreciate apprciate the
leadership the steadfast leadership of
of Todd and his team and you know since
2018 we've also built two new fire
stations we've been able to replace the
Frontline apparatus and we stalled over
2400 smoke detectors in homes across the
city we've also hired 26 new
firefighters which represents over a
third of our suppression staff the
future is bright for our Public Safety
teams okay we've also invested a lot in
our public park and in the process have
created more and better place spaces for
our
neighborhoods here we are in culleton
Park still Co times when we were
reminded about how critical it was to
have outdoor spaces and this day felt so
good um to be outside celebrating and be
in community after spending so much time
apart I just remember this day so
vividly because it was a day when I
finally was like able to realize hope
that there was going to be an end to
this
and Milbourne park named after Violet
Milbourne honoring her Legacy for caring
for others and U Plaza honoring honoring
Barney Yol our Olympian a man who broke
barriers and I also just want to point
out that pictured here also is Ron Ford
he's on the right behind the statue
holding the cane he was the first black
city council president who went on to
become a county commissioner Ron
recently passed away I wanted to say
rest in peace Ron and that you broke
barriers
too Longs Park Wetlands yes this is
storm water infrastructure but it's also
in a park and it's added a unique
destination within the park for visitors
to connect with nature and the bins Park
refresh so um we've done upgrades to
lighting Landscaping Painting and More
this is named in honor of James and R
roomie bins and here are their
grandchildren and great grandchildren
celebrating at the ribbon cutting and
those kids were cold after that because
it was early spring and they were
soaking wet but there's something about
that Fountain you just got to run
through
it and there's more to come the city
just finalized its next Park master plan
with an emphasis on reimagining three
Southeast neighborhood parks South End
Park Joe Jackson Tot Lot and the Ule
gance playground I'm really excited for
these projects to get
underway all right let's talk about
Paving second to parking I hear it all
the time mayor when are you going to
pave the street so on the right is a map
of the streets that have been paved
since 2018 to today in total there have
been 25 miles that have been paved which
is about 20% of all the streets in the
city the yellow streets represent work
that's been contracted out and the green
represents the streets that we have
paved because we have brought our Paving
operations inside we've been able to
save about a just over a million dollars
by doing this work inhouse and that
means we get to pave more streets with
that savings so the crew on the left are
a few of our dedicated DPW employees who
are getting the job done and I so
appreciate their
work 2024 was a big year for vision zero
we have 17 miles of bike Lanes now
and I take it as a personal victory that
people are complaining that we're not
clearing the bike Lanes fast enough
because now we have bike Lanes to clear
so uh we're going to continue doing um
more to uh support our um pedestrians
and bicyclists and our cars our drivers
safety in every neighborhood uh through
improved traffic calming and safety
measures uh and so you know it was
really nice to have secretary Pete come
and walk with me down Lemon Street and
get a nice shout out um we uh know that
these efforts are supercharged by safer
streets for all grant funding and
there's a lot more to come so
particularly in the Southeast
neighborhood South Duke Street Church
Street an and Juniata Chesapeake and
Broad Streets all are in
progress okay moving on lead you've
heard me talk about lead hazards and
this has been a focal point for me uh
for quite some time uh we received our
first record-breaking Grant to remediate
Lead South of King what what year was
that 2019 I think and since then our
team in cped has completed nearly
500 projects 500 homes and in October
yeah that's a lot
and in October we got the news that we
rewarded another $7.8 million from HUD
to keep that work
going this is just a small portion of
the grants we have under management
right now we are at 83 million do up
nearly 200% from just 2021 there's no
doubt about it grants power so much work
and we're paying a lot of attention to
what to the recent rulings that are
halting or uh delaying efforts uh to get
this money out into the communities that
have work
underway so follow along with
me and then last November voters in
Lancaster overwhelmingly adopted the
city's new home Rule Charter and this
indeed was a historic moment
I want to give a special thank you to
the home R study commission members that
are pictured here along with judge jod
Richardson I think I saw commissioner
mcgrand commissioner bird who else is in
here that I'm
missing Carl yes Carl
Feldman okay just keep calling out yeah
Pete Barber okay you get the
idea okay and Tony dastra thank you um I
just want to thank the Commissioners for
giving more the than a year of their
life to find a better path forward for
our city government these meetings were
hard and tedious and you spent a lot of
time in this space and I could not be
more grateful and with the passage of
the home Rule Charter came a long to-do
list that wow um we're working our way
through so the transition committee met
last week and heard from our solicitor
Barry hener about how we are approaching
the work so stay tuned for more as this
as this work unfolds um um there's a lot
to do in a very short amount of
time in addition to implementing the
home Rule Charter uh we've got a little
thing called our future Lancaster and
maybe you were here uh when we rolled
this out a couple years ago we've jumped
in feet first under the leadership of
Chris Del and his team uh in the
community planning and economic
development we have three small area
plans uh that are getting started you
may have seen U some information about
these out in the lobby uh they include
um the Northern end of the Sunnyside
Peninsula the East End including what
will soon be the former prison and the
stadium District around Clipper Magazine
stadium and the train station so lots
more to come as we Implement our uh comp
plan and then we also have the tourism
master plan which was also a part of our
comprehensive plan and that's going to
be finalized in the coming weeks I'm
really excited about this this is the
first 10-year City specific plan that
we've had for tourism development and it
really dovetails with our Governor's
focus on increasing tourism here in
Pennsylvania we um are going to embrace
this plan with an eye towards preserving
our historic Community empowering our
local economy and and enhancing the
quality of life for everyone tourism is
not just about other people but it is
about welcoming guests and on the map on
the left you can see our visitor data
between June 2023 and July 2024 that's
where where all the people came from to
visit us that's kind of amazing isn't it
so uh we know that about 16% of those
visitors are coming to the City by train
confirming that our amrak station has a
lot of potential and is a significant
asset which brings me to
Transportation this was another element
highlighted in the comp plan and 177% of
households in the city of Lancaster do
not have a car and 44% have one car car
meaning that our public transit our
walkability and our bike Network are
crucial for people to get to work get
health care go to the school go to the
store Etc so improving public
transportation and better connectivity
with Amtrak the bus station and added
bike rout bike routes are all part of
this I am eager to see continued
progress here from the South Central
Transit Authority and other partners in
the meantime we've continued to elevate
public Transportation through our
tutorials as part of Lancaster on the
Move series as well as our s uh as well
as supporting the microtransit
feasability study that scta is doing uh
as well and along with its public
participation plan so we're really
leaning in trying to help really develop
this micro microtransit project because
we know that our residents need to
connect to places in the county and
people in the county need to connect to
places in the
city what would a state of the city be
without talking about
housing it is the issue in every single
community in
America and back in 2021 we launched an
interim housing strategy outlining goals
for the next five years including the
creation of 2,000 new housing units and
15% of which would be affordable today
we are at 600 new units built
133% of which are affordable including
this project here by h
TC we have 950 additional units that are
in the
pipeline
however after all the work to get those
950 units through Land Development I'm
not sure that they're all going to come
out of the ground at least not this year
and this is due to a variety of factors
mostly related to financing costs and
just the uncertainty of this particular
moment we're talking about tariffs now
there's a lot of different pressures but
one of the things that I am grateful for
is that we were able to seize a moment
to be able to add to the housing stock
in the city to turn vacant parking lots
into buildings and I also recognize that
affordable housing will not be built
without
subsidy and our ability to provide some
subsidy was fueled directly by the
American Rescue plan Act and the funds
that we received and the support of city
council and dedic ating 25% of those
funds to housing and I know that this
will remain a challenge for future
administrations at every level of
government we have to figure this
out and in the
meantime we need to continue to address
homelessness in the city of Lancaster
one of the big highlights of last year
was the opening of The Clay Street
Shelter collocated at otterbine United
Methodist Church this
yeah this was more than two years in the
making this was two years in the making
after we found a site uh it's $3.2
million and fundraising is still going
on and there is no long-term committed
funds for operating the shelter so we
need to continue to
Advocate I know this does not solve our
housing crisis but overnight literally
there were significantly fewer people
sleeping Out of Doors I am really
grateful to commissioner Yoder who is
spearheading a county strategic plan to
build capacity in other communities
around the county we learned when the
shelter was operating on Prince Street
that over 80% of the residents or the
the people who are staying in the
shelter were were residents of Lancaster
County they were from all over the
county the city of alone cannot provide
services for the entire County and we
are caring and have been caring more
than our fair share of water relative to
homelessness every community in the
county every community in this County
needs a plan and they
need the community to speak up loudly
when there are efforts to actually
Implement
something but zoning fails because
residents don't want a shelter in their
backyard these are their
neighbors it has happened time and time
again we've seen it happen in epida
we've seen it happen in Colombia we need
to be louder in order to support our
residents across this
County and we also need to be louder in
making sure that the organizations who
are doing this work get vastly more
resources
so this is my call to action to you to
stay engaged on this particular issue
and to pay attention to not just what's
happening in the city but also what is
and isn't happening around the
county and while I'm on this
topic I just cannot thank enough the
work of the partners that are in this
space they are doing it because they
believe in serving others this is such
hard work the Lancaster County Homeless
Coalition tfold the Lancaster County
food Hub the Water Street Mission anchor
Lancaster blueprints for addiction
recovery and the numerous churches that
feed so many people in our community
every single day as well as the number
of other organizations that I did not
mention and please forgive me for
leaving you off the list it is truly a
blessing that we have so many resources
in our community and those resources
need to be where people live to
[Applause]
okay Switching gears I want to spend
some time talking about
water just read those numbers for a
minute I think about water a
lot as do many of our staff some Around
the Clock drinking water storm water
waste water all the water you don't want
all the water you do want all the water
you rely on every day to brush your
teeth make your coffee all the things
and we have some really significant
challenges ahead of
us first we've got some really old
infrastructure uh we've been working on
replacing the city's uh large diameter
uh water main which is about 6.2 miles
of pipe that looks like this I just
appreciate this picture because it gives
you the sense of scale of like how big
these pipes
are all in cost to do that 6.2
miles about $60
million we're about a third
in another challenge pasas also known as
forever chemicals you probably got a
letter about this very recently maybe
even today in the mail um while we are
currently under operating under State
guidelines uh the Biden Administration
also rolled out new regulations which
would effectively reduce the threshold
to zero
this is caught up in litigation right
now and we're also waiting to see how
the Trump Administration is going to
weigh in on this issue in the meantime
we've been doing our own testing where
is this posos coming from and lo and
behold it's coming from up
River and so we know that we need to
address what's happening up River
Upstream from our kosa treatment plant
because the all-in estimated cost to fix
this little problem $80 million
and how many of you know what your lead
line Looks
like yes all right yay thank you so in
Lancaster we know that lead paint is the
main culprit for our kiddos having
elevated blood lead levels however we've
got some new EPA regulations that are
requiring us to Fast Track the
elimination of lead lines in our water
system so while everybody should be
aware of whether or not you have a lead
line coming into your home please also
know that we are treating the water to
prevent corrosion and that lead leeching
that did not happen in Flint Michigan
these are the differences okay I just
want everybody to be clear that our
water is meeting all of the requirements
related to lead and Lead
monitoring but a big part of this work
is creating an inventory which is why I
asked did you know what you have in your
basement um so the most common are
copper plastic lead and galvanized metal
met we had to submit an inventory we did
that in October and also we need people
in the city and in the 10 municipalities
we serve to help us because just to
finish the inventory it could cost us
another $6
million and if you help us we can reduce
that amount and then the cost of
replacing the node the known lines we
have about 700 now out of 50,000 so this
just give you a sense of like we're not
talking about a lot but we are talking
about
some that's going to cost $19
million and now storm water so we signed
a concentree in
2017 uh to address our combined sewer
overflows the main goal being to reduce
those overflows into the conastoga river
when it rains and we've made progress
we've gone from about 65 a year to 48
which is a 26% decrease largely thanks
to our 200 rain Gardens and all the
other storm water infrastructure that is
around the city they're soaking it up
they're doing their jobs and I
appreciate that we've all gotten a lot
smarter about green infrastructure in
the city of
Lancaster I also just want to say this
is why storm water or I'm sorry why
street cleaning is mandated which is
that we need to keep the debris out of
our sewer system and in 2024 our street
sweepers
collected how many tons of trash give me
a guess no a little less than
that
341 tons of trash that's a lot of
trash so this is just your friendly
reminder to move the your car on street
sweeping days because we are required to
do this and in March we will submit a
final draft of our long-term control
plan for feedback from the EPA then mark
your calendars because on April 3rd
we're going to have a public meeting to
review in Greater detail the long-term
control plan itself the estimated cost
TBD but safe to say tens of millions of
dollars now if this has all got you
thinking about how on Earth can we
afford all of
this You are not
alone I've been crunching numbers on how
these mandates will impact water
affordability into the future and I am
very concerned about how families
especially our lowincome families will
afford these Rising utility
rates per EPA Guidance the same Federal
agency that is requiring us to spend all
this money states that families should
not be spending more than
4.5% of its median household income on
water a community should not spend more
than 4.5% of its median household income
on water obviously that masks the people
that are below the median household
income because they're they're going to
spend more than
4.5% and that concerns me because right
now 19% of our city households can't
afford their current City Water and
Sewer rates and with the added cost
complying with the mandates and
repairing and rehabilitating the systems
that we rely on every day
that could increase to
[Music]
43% that is not going to fly we have to
come up with a better
solution I am currently chairing the US
Conference of Mayor water Council and I
have been talking about water
affordability ad nauseum for the last 18
months or so and I was glad to see the
EPA acknowledge that affordability is an
issue nationally but how they will
abound balance the regulatory drivers
with affordability has yet to be
determined and a lot of it will depend
on the new
Administration
okay now I get to the Lessons Learned
part about what it means to have been
the mayor for seven years and a month
and a few days so many Lessons Learned
wow so I'm just going to share a few
with you lesson number one it all takes
longer than you think it
should and the example that I'm going to
give tonight just one of them is auto
pay I talked about this last year state
of the city address and said we were
going to get it
done and friends we did not get it
done we had repeated delays and I just
want to thank the treasury team for like
sticking this out because this has been
painful uh with our
subcontractor um to the point we had to
like withhold payment to get them to
actually do the thing that we needed
them to do so I'm delighted to tell you
it is coming and I'm also really afraid
to say exactly the date when but this
summer it's
coming and it and and maybe if I set
your expectations for late summer and we
deliver an early summer you'll be even
more excited so we are working really
hard on this but back to the lesson of
it all takes longer than you think it
should you know anything that requires
funding which is like everything all of
those Park projects I showed you earlier
uh came to be because we had to assemble
different sources of funding from
different pots of money in order to make
those projects happen and that takes
time and if for some reason we're not
successful in one Grant cycle and then
we have have to wait until the next
Grant cycle opens that adds a year just
like
that and another thing is Staffing you
know our executive leadership team tells
me this it's like you know mayor if I
you know if we had more bandwidth if we
had a bench if we had depth in our teams
so that we weren't just responding to
the crisis of the day but that we could
also be doing more more intentional
implementation of all the things the
list would go faster we are lean and
also if there's a vacancy for any reason
just add 6 to 12 months to any project
that we're doing because it's really
hard to ramp up when you've had a delay
and so I have learned that it all takes
longer than you think it
should lesson number two it really takes
longer when vision and culture are not
in alignment
wow um and
working in city government is not for
the faint of heart um there is little
room or Grace that's given for making
mistakes or like just having a bad day
um and people rely on us every single
day um and you know there's a lot that
we can't change about that Dynamic but
what we can do is really be intentional
about the culture that we are creating
inside our organization
uh in order to be able to meet the needs
of our residents so we're a big
organization we're 600 people we have
three unions uh and this work has been
done in every single
Department this really been painful as
well because we've had to make decisions
to get the right people and the right
seats so that we could move as one and
today that I can say without reservation
that the city's El executive leadership
team is not only committed to the work
at hand but it's committed to the people
who are doing the work and that really
matters now we don't get it right all
the time I will be the first to tell you
we are a Perpetual work in progress
because we're human and organizations
are made up of humans but we're
committed to getting it better getting a
bit better every single day and I am so
grateful that every one of the executive
leadership team members has you know
leaned into this through uh their own
personal leadership development working
with uh you know coaches to help them
build new teams um doing uh uh
performance feedback and 360 performance
feedbacks for themselves all of these
things matter and uh I just couldn't be
more proud of the people that I work
with and truly that is going to be the
thing that I'm going to miss the most
about this
gig okay lesson number
three um at the end of my very eventful
first year in office which I just did a
little recap of um I sent a letter to
the executive leadership team with a
quote by Theodore Roosevelt called The
Man in the arena this is probably
familiar to most of you I'm just going
to read the first line raise your hand
if you know what I'm talking about the
in the arena okay all right I knew you
would
too um it is not the critic who counts
not the man who points out how the
strong man stumbles or where the doer of
Deeds could have done them better the
credit belongs to the man who is
actually in the arena or in this case
the
woman most of you know that I played
field hockey for decades and I know what
it means to celebrate Victory and feel
the sting of defeat to trip fall Miss
score to carry my teammates off the
field when they blew out their ACL or
cheer them
on um and I have come to think about
this
job as if I'm on the field on a field
and a lot of people are watching
surrounded by my teammates coaching
staff who are critiquing and offering
advice and people in the stands who are
cheering for you to be successful
because we're all in it together whether
it's a game or because we all live in
this community
but there are some that
Revel in sitting in the cheap seats far
from the field the nose bleeds if you
will they uh are
loud they're mean they're calling me
names like Mar so lousy and other names
that I heard in third grade on the
school bus I mean like I've heard it all
um and over time I've learned that these
Vo
those people that I refer to as sitting
in the cheap seat matter very little and
that in life it's best to respectfully
ignore
them it sounds easy but sometimes anyway
um it matters much much more to listen
to your teammates and your coaches the
people who care about you and who are
willing in fact brave enough to tell you
when you don't get something right to
your
face and the cheapest
seats are the keyboard Warriors who
don't even show up to the game and these
are often the most emboldened and what's
not funny is the toll that that takes
particularly on women in office so this
is a survey of women Mayors uh that was
was recently completed by the mayor's
Innovation project this is not published
yet we just were going over this data a
few weeks
ago uh women Mayors reported harassment
more uh three more than
men as candidates and on the job and
experience that
harassment at least three times per
month women Mayers face significantly
more questioning of their abilities than
men more than two times and 40% reported
sexual harassment on the
job I can make fun of and make light of
what it means uh but I will tell you
that we have to be better than this
okay lesson number four only five people
are more than one thing even those
people that are sitting in the cheap
seats I'm not talking about people when
they are at their worst moment or having
a bad day we know that people are more
than that or at least I hope we do I'm
talking about the ways that people show
up that are at complete odds with what
you think they should be it's a
combination of how our brain works and
sorts and pigeon holes People based on
their political affiliation where they
live who they love if they shower before
they go to work or when they come home
when where they worship if they worship
the list is endless we are just
constantly sorting
people it is part of the human condition
and what I've tried to be as much as
possible and look I am not perfect at
this
is to be open to the ways that people
might surprise
me it has worked in both ways uh people
I've held in high esteem or those I
would have expected something more from
I don't know why um but I've been really
disappointed by and other people that I
may not have initially trusted for some
reason have shown up in ways I just
absolutely could not have predicted like
in really good
ways and I guess because I've learned
this lesson over time that people are
not are more than one thing uh this has
allowed me to Main maintain a level of
compassion and empathy we might not be
best buds but you know I've moved on
hopefully you have
too but it's really gotten me through
some difficult
conversations but it only works if the
other person is willing to see me as
more than one thing
too I'm not just a Democrat I'm not just
a mayor I'm not just a mom I'm not just
a wife I'm not just a Fillin the
blank I'm a person who has life
experiences and I'm curious and
interested to know what yours are
too
and what I have found is that when you
find the common ground especially today
that feels so elusive doors open and
possibilities emerge for things that you
can't even imagine and there is a
closeness that even if you're on
completely opposite spectrums on any
issue and let me tell you Democrats
don't always agree hello can I get a
amen for that um let alone if you're an
independent Republican what whatever you
are and you know why are we constantly
reducing ourselves to the initial after
someone's name we got to be better we
have to come together as a community and
a country we have much more in common
than what divides us and we have to not
be played we are being played
[Applause]
and last but not least lesson number
five this was my wedding day Christian
and I were walking down Charlotte Street
on the way to our wedding reception in
September of
1998 not in a million years would I have
imagined that I would be the mayor of
Lancaster no not ever
ever so there's really two lessons on
this slide
one it matters to have a partner in life
who loves you and who gives you extreme
Grace when you're having a bad day and
who shows up for you no matter what
thank you Christian
I love
you and number two say
yes I remember so clearly the first time
someone asked me if I was running for
mayor and I said yes out
loud I mean like that was
scary saying yes has led me here to this
moment
with all of you and I would do it all
over
again onward Lancaster thank you so much
for the honor of serving as your mayor
it's my pleasure and I got 10 more
months to
go thank
you thank you
10 months
to thanks St